so we get started
um okay uh so next we have uh
from Colombia talking to us about a
little bit more about non-hummitivity
non-commutativity and this will be like
we'll take a 10 minute break near the
end of the hour sure
all right all right so yeah I what I
planned is to uh tell you a little bit
about uh some of the rounding schemes
that are available to us in uh when we
study non-local games
uh but uh the class of not the cloud
games that I will focus on uh are really
special they're coming from uh uh
constant satisfaction problems classical
kind of satisfaction problem and because
of this connection uh I rarely ever uh
evoke any language uh that we usually
associate in other color games here and
there I point out that you know with
underlying this there is this non-local
game picture but that's that'll be all
but uh what constraint satisfaction
problems and uh why would they be
interesting for us in Quantum
information and uh what does rounding
even mean in this context so they will
all be clear in the next few examples
that I'm gonna present okay the first
one is uh is an example that most
everyone in the room has seen before
it's the magic square game uh it's the
classical
example of a constraint satisfaction
problem
where we have a three by three Square
the associated variable to every Square
X1 X2 to X nine and
they can take values in the set plus y
plus minus one and we have a bunch of
constraints we want the product of the
variables
in every row and column
to be one plus one
except that in the last column we
insisted the product B minus one
well we all know that this set of
constraints are inconsistent and we
cannot satisfy them all simultaneously
at once
but and this is interesting fact when
when you see it for the first time that
if we enlarge our domain if we go beyond
this plus minus one classical domain to
the class of unitaries with eigenvalues
that are plus minus one
we can satisfy the constraints perfectly
um
so if you allow ourselves to use Unity I
mean uh
and throughout the talk I'm going to
show operators using capital letters and
scalars using small letters and uh
if you require the rows and columns to
product and to multiply to I except for
the last one to minus sign and then we
can satisfy these using unitaries so we
require that
these be
unitaries and have eigenvalues that are
plus minus one
um
well
I mentioned to you that this is this is
a game uh but it didn't formulate it as
a game let's just quickly do that most
everyone has seen this example as a game
uh this is a game that is played between
a referee and two players Alice and Bob
um the referee chooses one of the rows
or columns and sends it to Alice and
also chooses one of the cells and sends
it to Bob and Allison Bob must respond
with assignments to the variables that
they receive
if they want to win they must be
consistent with one another and Alice's
assignment must satisfy the respective
constraint through or column that there
is she received
now but the mere fact that there's no
classical assignment to satisfy these
constraints
if Alice and Bob were restricted to
classical strategies if they were
classical and wanted to win this game
well their chance of winning is going to
be strictly less than one whereas if
they were allowed to use quantum
strategies because of the fact that you
can satisfy these constraints using
observables perfectly
uh they can win the game with value one
all right so there are a few points that
I want to make
first that you know uh this urge to try
to
um
uh plug in unitaries
in this set of constraints was not just
mathematical curiosity the magic square
game and this enlargement of the domain
to unitaries has found really deep
applications in Quantum information
right so it wasn't just mathematical
curiosity and the second point that I
want to make is that it's a very good
example of relaxation
which is going to be uh the topic of
this mini Workshop like relaxation and
rounding so the relaxation well we had a
set of constraints we couldn't uh
um satisfy them so we enlarge the domain
and we were able to perfectly satisfy it
and uh the relaxation always comes uh is
the uh you know precedes the rounding
which is the process with which we then
take these operators x i and extract
classical labels plus one minus one from
them
um
and uh here it just so happened that the
uh domain that we relaxed ourselves to
was the set of operators or if we don't
want to forget the algebraic structure
on the underlying the domain we might
say the uh we relax to Matrix algebra or
rings of operators right uh if you want
to insist not to forget the algebraic
structure uh and but you know this is
something this this type of type of
relaxation to operator algebra is or was
uh something that uh
it started happening when Quantum
information became a thing right
historically
you want to solve the constant
satisfaction problem the relaxation
domain usually was a vector space
so uh this is something that this
difference between Vector space it
reacts into Vector spaces or algebras
will become clear as we uh go on The
Talk
um all right so
um
my next example is also going to be
super important that one uh most of you
have
um
seen it uh as this class if not local
games known as xor games the most famous
example of which is the chsh game and uh
but uh I want to State uh closer to the
CSP kind of language so I'm going to
present it to you as as this constant
satisfaction problem known to us as Max
cut so I'm going to present it that way
and um
and it's going to uh
give us a recipe
for
relaxing any classical concert
satisfaction problem
to uh Matrix address okay so let's do
that uh Max Scott
an instance of Max Scott is
given to us by a graph
we are assigning a variable to every
vertex of the graph and these values
just like magic square can take values
in the set plus mine plus minus one
and we have a bunch of constraints uh
those constraints are that for every age
we want x i
to not be equal to x j for every n h i j
okay
and Max got simply asks how many of
these uh constraints can be satisfied
all at once
okay
uh now what would be useful uh
relaxation for this problem uh could we
just say that hey just like Max car this
is just like magic square try to like
assign unitaries that have arguments
that are plus minus one and I just
required that this unitaries be
different from each other that's a
little bit childish because you can
always do that there are infinite mini
operators you can always find distinct
operators for every vertex
really the useful relaxation
comes to us if we start thinking about
Max Scott as a polynomial optimization
problem so let's just let's formulate
Max God as a polynomial optimization
problem first and then see how we can
relax
so as a polynomial position it's going
to be as follows so consider this
expression x i 1 minus 6A is 3 divided
by 2. well uh this expression is always
there going to be 0 or 1. and it's going
to be one if and only if x i is not
equal to x j so if I sum it up
for some assignment x i x j over all the
edges it counts the number of edges that
assign different values for the
endpoints for the right so this is going
to be really if you maximize this this
is going to be
the max got problem viewed as a
polynomial optimization right and let's
you know spice things up and maybe add
weights for edges as well
okay
and now
um
we can do something similar to what we
did with the magic square now we can
require now we can ask what would what
would happen to this monomial if you
plug in unitaries with eigen values at a
plus minus one
uh
so let's do that just you know to be
precise we're going to maximize the
trace of the operator that we obtain
this is
um
subject to the constraint that these
operators are unitaries
and
they have eigenvatives that are plus
minus
okay
um
all right the first thing that happens
is that well this is really a relaxation
in the sense that this inequality is
true
plus minus one are also unitaries that
great
and but for it to be useful uh we have
to answer two questions first can we
solve this relaxation efficiently and
second if you solved it and obtained
this solution can be
extract or can be round it back down to
classical labels and obtain something
that is going to be a good classical
solution right we have to answer these
two questions and
um
well the first one the fact that this
can be solved efficiently is the content
of what's known as the serialism theorem
this
and the second one the fact that it can
be rounded to a good classical solution
is
the Gomez Williamson's High prevalent
rounding algorithm
okay and we're going to talk about these
two things
but really the goal of this talk
is to go beyond maxcote
and to see to what extent clsango
medicine can be extended
you know our Quest will be to find an
approximate sir lesson
and an approximate
comments video soon four problems Beyond
Max Skype that's that's what we're going
to try to do but first of course we have
to see the original CLS on and
commencement right
um and uh
so let's do that
first uh I'm gonna present to you guys
Williamson
not with all the detail you you've uh
I'll say most likely before so just
gonna very briefly remind ourselves what
Gomes Williamson was and remind us of
what Siri lessons was right uh all right
so
I'm going to actually erase this because
I want the board to be
not a chaos
as much as possible so
comments on set out to solve first we
are going to do commands videos
they set out to solve this uh classical
concentration problem that was their
goal and the relaxation they chose was
not the one that I wrote down it was not
too non-commutative like uh world it was
two Victoria spaces so they said let's
imagine these XI is now instead of being
plus minus one they are vectors with
Norm one okay and
um that's this is this uh problem is a
relaxation they considered
ISB now vectors and then relax the
quadratic terms into inner products
it'll be clear once I wrote down this
um
it's maximize over vectors of this
expression subject to the constraint
that
X i's are Norm 1 vectors
again it should be clear that this is a
relaxation uh you know
but
um we have to answer those same
questions can we solve this efficiently
and uh can we um
the answer to the first question whether
we can solve this efficiently
is is a little bit easier than the
non-commutative case actually this
is not too difficult to see that this is
a semi-definite program and we can solve
it efficiently so as so as as far as we
can solve same different programmings
efficiently so let me write it down as a
semi-definite program and then we can
very quickly prove that this is the case
this equality holds
um
so this is maximization uh like a linear
uh function of the entries of a matrix X
where the Matrix X is
just a n by n Matrix that is positive
semi-definite
and
has
one
in the diagonal entries
and
why the value of these two problems are
the same well One Direction is very easy
this
direction is super easy if you have a
bunch of vectors
a feasible solution
let's call this the vector problem and
this is the STP
if you have a physical solution to the
vector problem then you can just form a
matrix X from those vectors by just
packaging those inner product in a
matrix like this
I'm not going to elaborate this should
be clear like you know have uh label
your
columns and your
rows
by the vectors and uh in the in every
entry you would put the corresponding
inner product of the column and row then
you immediately get that this Matrix X
is going to be positive some definite
and
um
the diagonal entries by virtue of the
fact that these vectors are Norm 1
are going to be one
so it's going to be feasible in the STP
solution and
the objective functions are exactly the
same so it's going to achieve the same
objective value as those vectors in the
vector problem
and the other direction also is super
simple but let's also quickly see
this other direction
if now I have
an X that is feasible in this STP
problem I can always from the fact that
it's a positive summative Matrix write
it down or decompose it
like this for another Matrix V and then
uh obtain my Vector to be just The
Columns of this
decompose Matrix V
now
again from the fact that the diagonal
entries of X are one we get that
these are Norm 1 vectors so they're
feasible in this problem and they
achieve the same objective value as
density so
so we can't solve the vector problem
efficiently
once we obtained it once we obtain those
vectors how can we round it back to
those classical labels plus minus one
well that's the hyperplane rounding
and let's also remind us ourselves what
that was so if uh for for that uh well
you obtain this bunch of vectors
you
sample a vector R from the unitosphere
from the heart measure on the unit
sphere
and then you let
the labels to be just a sign
of the inner product of the vector r
with every Vector x i
okay so you obtain some random variables
and
uh
with a little bit of analysis when you
show that
the expectation of this random variable
here is going to be not too far
from
the analogous
vector
expression
this row here this constant row being
the commands with option constant of
zero eight seven eight
okay
and this is the expression that shows up
in our objective function right and this
inequality immediately shows that the
random assignment that we obtain from
this
rounding is going to achieve a value
that that is an expectation is going to
be at least 0 0.878 times the STP value
okay
all right but uh
what I promised to you was that uh there
is a way to solve the non-commutative
problem that I wrote down and uh and
that there is a rounding for that for
that solution back to classical labels
so we will quickly do that uh and then
uh we move on to other constraint
satisfaction problems all right so
um let me see how much of this uh
yes
well
uh it's going to like so the max Cuts
now
is going to be at most STP value of
course
and going to be at least row times
the STP value so it's going to be
sandwiched between uh you know
everything and you have a way of
constructing a value a solution with
this quality
all right so and here is uh
well
um
let me not assume equality yet but uh
this was the non-commutative but I
didn't give it the name but let's call
it down commutative Max Scott
and we don't want to confuse that with
its cousin quantum maxcard
which John will talk about later today
um and it was a problem of optimizing
the trace of this polynomial
okay so
um I said that there is a way to
efficiently solve this problem and uh
well uh
and I told you the name of the theorem
that does that it's the serialism
theorem and
the content of which is just this
equality
that that this non-committing Max code
is really the same as the vector the
optimal value is the same as the optimal
value of the vector problem
um
now
One Direction should be
easy to see like in the sense of like
you know improving it this
by proving two inequalities this
direction
should be easy to see because if we like
uh so I'm going to just rewrite this
problem instead of Trace I'm going to
just write it down as uh
you know it's just the same
I was writing this as the Herbert
Schmidt inner product of x i x j but
here that is schmitting a product really
does not care about the operatory
structure of the of these uh things
right it just looks at the matrices as
as if they are vectors so if you forget
the unitariness if you forget that they
are operators
you recover
really a solution to the vector problem
so this inner quantity should be obvious
this other direction
is also not that difficult
so again
uh the strategy that we're going to take
is as follows we have a bunch of vectors
X1
2x n
from them
we want to construct
a bunch of operators
X1 to xn
such that they are feasible in this
problem
and if you can show that
this up this operation going from
vectors to operators preserves the inner
products
then
we have shown that this operator
solution that we found is going to have
the same objective value as the vector
is in the vector problem all right so
how can we do that it's done through uh
a special set of operators known as
vilebra operators
so for every n
there's a bunch of special operators
Ryan also mentioned this in the in his
talk there are a bunch of operators
Sigma 1 to Sigma n
uh such that they're also they're
themselves
um unitaries
they also have eigenved instead of plus
minus one and furthermore the
anti-communities
Now the recipe for going from the
vectors to operators is as follows
if your vector x i
has these n entries
and you just construct your operator x i
to be just a linear combinations of this
special operator Sigma I
with coefficients that are coming from
okay
now from from the first two facts from
the first two properties of Sigma I's
the Unitarian s and order two Nets of
the of these efficient operators
it's just very simple algebra to show
that X I also would be feasible in the
sense that it would be unitary and order
two
and also
using the fact using the uh this third
property you can show that
the inner product is also preserved so
that that property I wrote down over
here is also preserved
so that
this was all our needs and this
construction does what we wanted it to
do
okay any questions about this
yes
I didn't quite understand what the
statement of citizens came was like is
it just like that yes it is it is uh the
state the statement is that
so I wanted to tell you that this can be
solved efficiently this non-commutative
Max problem can be solved efficiently
and uh
Siri listen does it by showing that it
is equal its value is equal to sdp uh
and so that's what we are trying to show
like I told you that this direction was
easy because you can just forget about
the operator instructor and just get
that and then this other direction goes
through uh transforming your vectors
constructing operators from your vectors
right that would have this property and
in the statement of the non-communition
yeah
there's no constraint but uh from this
construction you can always uh you know
you always get something that the
dimension
is at most two to the end
because
we understand the representation theory
of this algebra variable great and we
know that there is always an irreducible
of Dimension to the end for this
which properties are you using to ensure
that this linear combination of
unitaries
oh all three actually you have to use
all three yeah you use that computation
yeah
good point and Anand oh yeah I guess one
difference from this morning is that you
have the trace absolutely
yes I don't know if there's anything to
say about this problem but with random
acts instead of Trace
um
yeah so um you know um
there was this there is this way of
looking at this uh problem also as a
game I mentioned that some of you have
seen it as an xor game right and if you
do it that way and you allow eigenvalue
maximum eigenvalue here then this expert
this optimization problem is going to be
giving you the quantum value of that
Associated extra game
that's if you have the bipartis
structure between Alice and Bob
right yes
maybe it's not even natural it's like
exercise
yes and you might you know and you
notice that uh the problem that Ryan
wrote uh had a worse approximation ratio
than uh like this in fact you can solve
efficiency right whereas that one was
like one over log n of like you know STP
and
um so it could be because
uh I consider the eigenvalue
right but we're going to say that this
Trace approach is going to be closer to
work you know if our goal is to solve
the classical thing this seems to be uh
also interesting or like you know
and the trace is always like smaller the
trace is always smarter than Nike
because it's going to be the average of
the eigen values exactly
yes
the right hand side with these
exponentially large matrices yes but
they are you know the specific
structures they have just incredible
percentage they have yeah is it going to
be the case that the solutions will
always be these very large matrices for
other customers
right so uh if we restrict answer to
maxcard yeah you can expect that you
would lose a little bit of uh
you know you you lose a little bit of
value and you can uh realize it over uh
polynomial or large matrices instead of
exponentially large that's yeah uh just
doing some Metric embedding type of type
of things yeah exactly yeah uh but no uh
uh we know that uh to achieve the exact
value you're gonna have uh you're gonna
you're gonna need to go to exponential
size matrices
but I can always but if I just want a
small apartment yeah exactly you can do
you can you turn it up to a polynomial
science matrices polynomial being like
the end number of vertices of the graph
yes
are you using like the normalized trace
I'm using normal assist thanks so much
for bringing that up yes exactly yeah
uh
um
what does Sigma a look like well uh
there is a way to construct them it will
take us a little bit uh far from like
what I have planned for the talk we are
going to see actually generalization of
these things when we move on to other uh
constant satisfaction problems and there
I will tell you a little bit about how
we produce the representation but it's
not too difficult it is it is uh
arranging the power operators in a
special
um like uh it's going to be tensor
products of power The Operators arrange
in a way that you would achieve this
um you know power The Operators would
always either commute an anti-commute so
you want to choose those uh elements of
the party operator that just
anti-commute with one another pairwise
their form is the products
each one is about product problems yes
yeah it's one of them is a transfer
product of balance exactly
yes yes
um all right so let's uh now try to see
okay so we saw that uh serialism
answered one of the questions the other
one is also incredibly just exactly like
uh you know the the one of us was the
other question let me remind you the
other question was now that we have the
non-commutative solution can we extract
from its classical solution well this
point is a little bit much because we
you know I told you that these two
problems are the same and I already told
you how to round the vector problem to
the classical solution but bear with me
uh there's a point why I try to kind of
write it formulate it this way right so
but that rounding uh
a scheme that I already gave you for
comments you know by Goldman's video
soon it's going to give us a way to
round these non this non-commitive
solution also to those classical uh
labels let me write it down very quickly
so um
again it's exactly just as before just
choose r
uh uniformly from the
hypersphere and uh let's operator R be
uh
the linear combinations of these
valuable are operators and then
just from the fact that this this you
know uh and and let the you know and
let the uh rounding be just like before
and
just from the fact that this
um kind of transformation going from
vectors to operators preserves the inner
product
you just have uh
we just recovered the comments with the
Thompson and just from the same analysis
as before you can get that expectation
of this
uh random variable that is important for
us because it shows up in our objective
function is going to be not too far from
the operator
value
the operator analog of the expression
okay so there's nothing magical that I'm
saying here it's just you know uh but I
phrase it in terms of operators because
we want to uh I told you that we want to
go we want to generalize
or attempt to generalize seal this one
and attempt to generalize command speed
up so so let's uh it might be useful to
have this uh operator view okay I'm
sorry so so here it is these operators
foreign
to be the same as the vector X and Y
that re this this one really relies on
coming up with the basis Sigma 1 to
Sigma n like if if X and Y are just
linear combinations of Sigma some Sigma
I Sigma n
right as long as the sigma i's are
orthonormal
form an orthonormal basis for the set of
matrices then you have this property and
they do satisfy that right because of
this yeah exactly so one I was hoping I
was just not seeing it off the top of my
exactly
yeah because if
imagine Trace um if I just take take the
trace of these two
uh then uh the bicyclicity of Trace I
would get that this is
Sigma I Sigma J and so it must be zero
and so
by you know inhale British mid inner
product it has to be orthonormal but
that's not necessary that's not that's
not all uh sufficient because we want we
you know we don't want just up to trace
to have this anti-commutation or we
don't want just orthonormality we want
really the structure of this algebraic
relation because that is going to be
what we need to prove that the x i is
unitary and order two
right
sorry there's something else I've missed
um it's sort of a naive question with
what so what's the
we would imagine one one goal here would
be look you know you had a relaxation
and then you say well look but maybe we
want a better relaxation yes we want
more constraints so this you know the
structure that we're extracted more
constraints and then serial sudden is
coming back and saying it's
disappointing you know once here exactly
large dimensions so so was this a
disappointment or was it a
okay so in the case of Max cut we were
actually not hoping that this
non-commutative approach is going to
give us a better approximation because
up to UNI games conjecture the uh this
ratio that we have here is going to be
uh optimal okay so we were not hoping uh
to gain something from the non-committed
Mexico but the moment we move on to
constant satisfaction problems that are
not Max Scott the picture is not as
clear especially when we don't have the
unicame uh
um sharpness of the approximation ratio
right um so uh so but we still wanted to
kind of motivate it through Mexico
because everything is just clean and
everything just is working out but yes
it's disappointing that it doesn't give
us something larger but
another way that I motivated it was that
this value here is already super
important anyway in Quantum information
because this is the Quantum value of uh
uh of a synchronous
uh this is the synchronous value of
the xor game that arises from this Max
cut instance so all of these
non-committed problems that I'm going to
write down underlying them there is a
non-local game and uh that uh polynomial
optimization is giving you exactly the
quantum value of that download whereas
the this the classical polynomial gives
you the classical value
all right
uh let's uh
all right so
um
if we want to generalize this and uh
so what kind of concept satisfaction
problem are we going to consider right
uh
so let's
um
there is a large family of
constant satisfaction problems that
contain Max cut and also unique games
and some you know some other problems
but uh among them like I just wanted uh
you know like choose one
satisfaction problem that is not Max God
and on which we can apply some of these
ideas uh so I
chose Max 3 card because it's already
super close to Max Scott right uh and
would get us there we can use it as a
vessel to apply these ideas and so max
three cut again every instance is given
by
a graph the associate to every vertex
a variable but this time this variable
instead of taking binary values
they're going to be one of three they're
going to be like here I chose one Omega
and Omega squared where Omega is the
third root of unity
so the options here are third root of
unity
okay and constraints are exactly the
same as Max cut we want x i to not be
equal to x j for every h i j
all right let's take this and try to see
how much of the story we can we can push
forward okay and first we want to focus
on CNN so first we want to understand
whether we can solve the non-commutative
analog of this problem efficiently
then we worry about whether we can round
it back to a classical solution okay in
the second part of the talk as much as
much time you know as much as I can
um
but uh so we know the drill
yes but when you were describing the
optimization earlier in terms of The
Operators yes
um
it wasn't always right so yeah we can
always assume that the objective
function is real because we were taking
Trace and uh
the medievances where her machine
actually because uh maybe I should have
rotated it down like that because we we
want we wanted unitary and we wanted
uh we wanted these two conditions so
this forces the eigenvaced to be plus
one minus one and it's going to be
already normal so it's going to be
hermitian right yeah
that point actually was going to be even
more important in the case of magnetic
the the whether the solution will be
real all right so uh so all right we
know that real we know that we have to
write this as a polynomial so let's do
that quickly uh the expression of it the
expression here will be a modification
of what we saw uh in the case of
in the case of Max cut
so this expression here for every Edge i
j and here A Star is just complex
conjugate when I put it on a scalar it's
a company's conjugate when I put it on a
matrix it's a hermitian conjugate so
this expression here is going to be
either 0 or 1
when X i's are these values and it's
going to be one if and only if x i is
not equal to x j okay so again just like
before if I sum up all of these
with the uh
with the weights hopefully you don't
confuse this with Omega
and uh and maximize this
I'm going to have
I'm going to have captured the max 3D
cut problem
is it clear hopefully it's uh so this is
just very similar to what we did for
maxcode and let's just quickly go and
write down the non-commutative analog so
non-commutative max 3 card
is going to be this polynomial
optimization
so just like before instead of plugging
in uh third root of unity we want to
plug in unitaries that have eigenvalues
that are third to definition right so uh
yes
some complex number oh no this is going
to be real because uh so it is
is the same yes exactly yes you know
this is just playing the role of x i XJ
divided by two in the case of Max cut
where X I's were just second root of
unity but now it's the third Revenue so
we have a complex conjugate
and all right so uh
this is going to be uh like we are
maximizing the trace of this
non-competitive polynomial now we have
x i star XJ
hopefully this x and x i and x j are
capital enough to show that they are
unitaries they're operators subject to
the constraint that
they are unitaries
and now we want them to have eigenvalues
that are certain Affinity so we just
want them to be order three right that's
um okay all right so this is
uh the problem that we are trying to
solve
and again there is a not local game
behind it we don't need to you know kind
of like elaborate on those anymore but
uh
uh let's do as much as we can just like
what we did for with Searles on and Max
Scott we can write down a vector problem
uh also Associated to max3 cut let's
also write that down very quickly Max
maximizing uh
so 2 minus
vectors
now I'm not going to elaborate that this
Vector problem
is an STP it's exactly like the argument
that I gave in the case of Max skirt but
what is its relation to NC Max 3 cut
it should be clear that it's somehow
related but like what is the
relationship
well again just like before if you
forget the structure the operator is
structure we immediately get
this inequality
okay
and if we had serialism we would have
had the equality
but we're not going to be able to have a
serialism they are very simple very
simple instances of max3 card where this
inequality is strict
okay so we cannot hope to get equality
all right
but again let's try to push as much as
we can uh just like in the case of Max 3
cut so we can solve this very
efficiently so we have these vectors X1
to xn
uh maybe I should
go to the other side of the bird
so I have this vectors
X1 to xn now
right and I hope that I could find some
special operator Sigma 1 Sigma and we
will see what they might be but just
doing the same drill as before we want
to be able to construct
this operator is X I from the vectors
so that they are linear combinations of
these special operator Sigma I's
eyes in the case of Max cut they were a
wild bear operator they satisfied all
our needs
but
so
what are some properties that we we need
to have for it to Sigma ice well
a moment of thought shows that if uh if
we want first of all one of our
requirements is that we want X I's to be
unitary
we want this exercise to be feasible
here right so we want them to be unitary
and we want them to be order three
and
we want their inner product
to be as
much as possible close to the inner
product of the vectors
right we saw that in the case of Maxwell
This is what these very important
properties have been needed these two
are essential we need these two unitary
and order three
all right so if you want this unitary in
order to leave we immediately get that
the sigma eyes must themselves be
unitary and order free so let's write
down the properties that we want from
Sigma ice
Sigma 1 to Sigma n the first property
that we want is that we want them to be
unitaries themselves
we want them to be order three
it's not too difficult to see why we
need these two because
so I wanted x i to be unitary in order
three for any Vector X I right
so I can just imagine Vector one zero
zero zero eight and that's uh so I I
need this to hold but I also need
expect to be unitary for for any sort of
factors that I would choose like not any
but like you know vectors that are
that their Norm two is one
that the unit Norm Vector is x i
so for that to happen to uh
I'm gonna need
something that is going to look like
anti-commutation but it's not quite
anti-commutation
just like exactly like the web hour case
if I want X I's to be unitary
I'm going to need this algebraic
relation
there's no question about that this like
if you do the algebraic manipulation you
would have to need that this sort of
anti-commutation must be true it's
different from anti-composition because
we have this adjoint operator here
right and something that I'm going to
write down three prime because we also
want order three and for order threeness
again doing some algebraic manipulation
you want this homogeneous polynomial
for water Fitness you want this extra
really algebraic relation all right so
this is this seems a little bit weird
but it's actually this is closer to what
you know being Quantum information would
be familiar with because one way to
satisfy this really strange looking uh
condition is to enforce that Sigma I
Sigma J is equal to Omega
Sigma J Sigma I
it's almost canonical way of satisfying
this would be would be this
okay so again both here and here we have
like some
modified modified anti-commutation let's
call them exotic anti-commutation right
so that two uh exotic anti-communition
at Play
now
I wrote down for you an algebra
presentation I wrote down a generic set
of generators and set of relations
does this algebra exist
well of course it does I wrote down the
presentation that's uh
the important question to ask is whether
it's interesting whether there would be
a representation for this algebra
non-trivial
well the answer to that question is
resounding no
we cannot do that
because if there are multiple way to do
that uh but playing with this
relationship or just writing down the
group near basis for the ideal generated
by these relationships you would get
that one
must be equal to zero in this algebra
which means that everything in this
algebra must be zero so it's the Zero
Dimensional algebra so it's not
interesting and the reason for it is
that these two relationships these two
exotic anti-commutations are
inconsistent with one another
if you
uh sacrifice one of them you can always
build representation so for example if
you sacrifice this one
and just want to achieve this one this
is going to be generalized uh probably
operators the clock and shift
Construction
if and we're familiar with that but this
one if if you forget this one and want
to satisfy this one
that's a little bit less familiar but
like for example when n is equal to 2
this is gonna the group that is going to
generate for forget about the algebra
the group that Sigma 1 and sigma 2 is
going to generate is going to be the
alternating group of degree four and we
understand it's representation very well
and we know that it has an
anti-representation and you know that
satisfy these
so and in fact this is true for all n if
we you know try to
kind of sacrifice the three prime we
would be able to construct
representations for this and I
uh may talk about it a little bit
later so now
and and we kind of knew that this is
going to happen we knew that we're not
going to be able to satisfy all these
things because I said that
uh this this inequality here is a strict
right
um
so something has to give we are
designing an approximation algorithm and
this is the place that we have to
sacrifice something so yes go ahead but
that's like the reason that's true is
that if all one two three prime is true
then you would have exact equality
exactly exactly you would have this
you I mean uh yeah and you would have uh
unitary and you would have ordered three
so the solutions that you got are the
the vector solutions that you got you
can transform them to operators and
their eigenvalues sorry the inner
product is going to be exactly the same
so if I drop the inner part of the
position but this problem
like how does that change the conditions
oh actually so I I didn't even worry
about this at all it just comes
automatically like this is in fact
satisfied even if if I forget this one
or if I forget this one in either case I
would get this
it's this only relies on this only the
only thing we need for this one is that
this form these are orthonormal matrices
and we can do that
okay but uh satisfying these two or
satisfying these two properties is the
difficult one
so I have to kind of satisfy like if I
forget this one
I'll be able to get for uh free that
xi's are unitary but then my rounding in
my rounding because I'm designing an
approximation algorithm right I'm going
to get x i that is a unitary now I'm
going to have to find a way to round it
down
to a unitary that is order three
and if I forget about this and you know
if I sacrifice this one then I have to
um so maybe this is a good time to take
that 10 minutes break
uh and then I can continue with this uh
okay
so we saw that we have to sacrifice
something
um and uh so that's the thing that's the
that's the interesting thing that
happens when we want to solve the
classical constant satisfaction problem
we didn't have to make this choice we
usually just you know relax to Vector
spaces and that's it but here we wanted
to solve a non-community optimization
problem we have to kind of choose what
algebra we want to relax ourselves to
right so we had a choice for example
here so every problem would afford you
some choices and you have to make this
decision and each one that you make is
going to give you a different
approximation ratio the qualitative the
different approximation algorithm
um also uh but so here we wanted to have
this ideal scenario where we would have
all these properties so that we would
have all these other properties here for
x i and we saw that we couldn't but a
beautiful thing happens if we
um
if we imagine we take one two and three
or maybe I can just keep using the blue
uh if we keep the properties one two and
three and just sacrifice the three prime
they are going to get for free the
unitary x i
but then we may ask okay how close is
this
to an order three unitary it turns out
that it is very close so if you for
example uh like so your XI is just a
linear combinations of the sigma J's if
you choose this Vector at random
and if you look at the complex plane and
the unit circle
you're going to see that the eigenvalues
of X i's are going to be scattered
around the
third root of unity
if they were third with affinity we
would have had order three unitary right
so depending on how well you can prove
such a statement depending on okay so
another chance that you have to make is
this metric for closeness right you
sacrifice the order sereness
but in some Metric here I'm suggesting
for a business Norm because I'm talking
about the eigenvalues you would be close
to another three unitary right and
uh
so you have to make a choice and we're
going to see that it's going to affect
our approximation ratio
um
similar thing happens when we sacrifice
the unitariness and get only the order
threeness then again linear algebra just
like here would tell us a way to round
it to a unitary that is order three
right so for example like I mean I can
at least quickly like if x i
has the singular value decomposition
that is U star DV where D is a diagonal
matrix and u and v are some unitaries
uh
you're guaranteed by linear algebra that
if you forget about D and just
great XI as ustrv this is going to be
the closest order three unitary that you
could possibly find in fruminous Norm to
this order three operators that you have
that originally wasn't wasn't a unitary
right so linear algebra is going to
provide you with these ways of like
doing your rounding right but
uh you know this was
up to the frobenius norm so maybe maybe
that that is a good choice for the
approximation algorithm that you want to
design maybe it's not so let's make a
few of these choices and come up with an
approximation algorithm and analyze it
for Max 3 cut right yes so stuck on your
position three because they say this is
x i is unitary equalism
so I said that
you almost certainly have to get these
two relationships right from the fact
that you want this to be true for any up
Vector so in particular if your vector
XI is one zero zero
zero
right it means that the operator that
you would get this x i that you
constructed is going to be Sigma I Sigma
1 in this case and so
um
if you require excited to be unitary and
or the freedom Sigma I must be
integrated so these two you get from
special choices of vector and then if
you want this to be true for all vectors
then you have to have this product
but good question thank you so now
um
all right let's go with these choices
that we have here one two three
we get the unitary
and
unfortunately the linear algebraic
approach is going to give you an
approximation ratio that is going to be
slightly less than
what I am going to present to you here
so uh so I'm going to present you the
better approach okay
here and it makes sense because there's
nowhere here
we said anything about rubinious Norms
so it doesn't make you know kind of like
uh
anyway uh maybe you know kind of like
you have to be smart about choosing the
metric that you want like you sacrifice
something you want to know how close you
are to that thing that you sacrificed
that closeness you have to Define in a
certain way and we're going to see it
now so we have we had a unitary x i
and uh we want to get an order three
unitary from it so we want to round it
to an x i hat that is order three
unitary
in this rounding procedure
we do the following
we say send x i to this slightly bigger
Matrix
constructed as false
it's a deterministic rounding algorithm
you have the x i you produce this bigger
Matrix yes
[Music]
yeah
with
um you know you look at the diagonal
element and you replace it with the
closest
oh that's uh that's that's the other so
if you if you preserve unitarians and
you wanted to get order three that's the
approach that you take if you wanted to
if you had order three and you wanted to
get unitary you have to forget that D
completely and replace it with identity
you have you can prove this that this is
up to forbidius Norm this is going to be
the closest order three unitary to to
you
but here we took the unitary approach so
the thing that you mentioned is going to
be the way to do it so you just look at
the eigenvalue in the specular
decomposition you just find the closest
root of unity to it and that's it that's
going to give you the operator that is
but that is going to give you give us
something that is a slightly less
inapproximation ratio in here
um all right so
this is a very simple exercise that if x
i is any unitary operator if you put it
this way you are going to get an order
three unitary this is the clock and
shift that we are familiar with
and
um
all right so this is let's call it X
I hat
that's it that's our rounding unlike
command screen option which was
randomized this is germanistic and we're
going to analyze it we're going to
analyze it and try to find out what is
the approximation ratio okay let's do
that so um
um
maybe I can do it in this little space
here
so analysis
so what is important in the analysis is
to be able to calculate the trace
of this x i star XJ well one thing that
I didn't mention to you is that because
this is hermitian
we can always assume that in any optimal
solution this x i is these vectors are
going to be real so don't worry about
that these these two inner products
would have different values or be
conjugate of each other they're going to
be the same they're going to be real and
the same thing here the trace of this
guy and this guy are going to be the
same so we we have a real structure so
the trace of this guy is going to be x i
the inner product of XJ
sorry and this is the one that we want
to calculate the rounded operators the
feasible solution this x i hat is the
feasible solution here
now uh this inner product is very easy
to calculate two-thirds of the time it's
going to be the inner product of x i x j
and one third of the time it's going to
be the
this let's call it garbage
with which makes sense because two out
of three
of the entries of x i hat are x i and
one of them is the garbage and if you
take this in a product it's a simple
exercise that you would get this
okay
and now if it was the case that x i
was unitary
and it is unitary if it was a order
three unitary
let's call it three unitary if it was
that then x i star
x i minus X I raised to the minus 2 is
going to be just x i
okay then this inner product would have
been
just the same as Dana powder if they say
nxj
if you know it's not the case in reality
this is not
it's just a unitary it's not order three
but
those things that I mentioned like for
example if you plot it in uh you know
plot eigenvalues you're going to see
that you're going to be close to roots
of unity well
we we expect this x i to be close to
being order three okay and here is the
metric with which we're gonna measure
this closeness so we want we you know uh
what we want from uh for this proof is
to show that well this this guy is not
going to be equal but we want it to be
close
to what it would have been if x i is
very unitaries
okay
sorry that I'm trying to give this as a
tutorial type of thing so that like we
can apply to other problems and you know
so it's kind of like you know applying
this attempt and like you know that was
forbinius and it fails and now this this
uh
other approach so now we uh this
is in fact something that we have
it just turns out that this inner
product is really
x i x j well it's not exactly x x j but
this X2 squared in a product of x i j
squared
when completely
from this algebraic relations of the
sigma is it follows from the
representation theory of the algebra
okay maybe I can say a few words later
on about that but it's not a difficult
fact difficult thing to prove uh but it
starts from the representation theory of
that algebra not just from those
algebraic relations so you cannot just
look at this and try to hope to prove
that uh
this is going to be true
not choosing this algebra if you choose
this algebra which we let's call it I
didn't give it a name let's call it
generalized valver hour
gwb
okay
which is the name of a bridge in New
York so
and um
so
so but but if you trust that this is
true then we can we can prove a very
good approximation ratio let's do that
so uh
now
yes
um for these General generalized this
generalized can you give me the
structure of basically the structure oh
yeah yeah yeah absolutely will you give
me a moment after after this I'm going
to get into the represent how to
construct the representation of this
algebra essentially it's going to be
very very much similar to what uh we saw
with Firepower polygroup is going to
play a very important role you know if
valibar will just power The Operators
just a specially selected power
operators that anti-commit with one
another here
uh well it's going to be a subgroup
that is generated by this group
uh the powers are going to be just uh
you know how do you construct tensor
products or parodies and you would get
the larger penalty groups like for any
number of generators you have a powder
group PN right and uh which is
constructed from the previous one by
tensor product so that's exactly the
kind of extractor that will happen here
but in a subgroup of this one let me say
a few words after after we are done with
this one so now let's finish the
analysis uh
hopefully it's okay if I write here so
this is the
this is what we are trying to
this is the expression using this
quadratic law here
and everything else that I mentioned
this is going to be uh 2 minus
4 over 3
x i x j
and minus 2 over 3 x i x j squared
divided by 3.
but
uh
these operators are orthonormal again
from the representation theory of this
group this algebra so the inner product
of the operator is x i x j that are
constructed from as to be linear
combinations of these special operators
is going to be the same as the inner
product of the vectors
all right so we are getting closer and
closer to the to this form
okay but we have a quadratic term
but uh it's
a simple exercise this quadratic
polynomial in the inner product can be
decomposed uh to be this uh expression
here I'm going to write it STP
times one linear factor is going to be
this one and the other linear factor is
going to be 1 plus 1 3 of the inner
product x i
and x j
one plus one third okay
but now uh
something that I didn't tell you is that
in any optimal solution of the vector
problem you can always assume that the
inner product of two vector
is at least minus half
this is not too difficult to show
but this must this must hold in any
optimal solution you can always assume I
mean there could be Optimal Solutions
that this doesn't set this up but you
can always get an optimal solution for
which this is satisfied
so
if you apply that we get that this term
is going to be at least five over six
and so this is going to be at least
five over six
STP
so all in all we proved that uh
remember I said that I don't want the
board to get chaotic well this is what I
meant
we get that NC
Max 3 cut
is at most the value of the STP
and at least five over six the value of
the STP
okay
that's what these choices that we made
is going to get us there
this is a deterministic approach we have
a randomized rounding approach that we
have uh still uh not fully done with all
the details so I'm not going to present
it here but we think that that is going
to achieve
13 over 15.
approximation ratio and uh
and I'm willing to conjecture that that
is the the 13 over 15 is the integrality
gap of this non-commutative STP
like meaning that there is an instance
for which you cannot go beyond 13 over
50.
the best that you could hope for would
be set in over 50.
all right so uh
and there's no reason to stop at Max 3
cut
um there is this large class of
um
constant satisfaction problems yes
the value of the integral optimal
solution for back to cut
yeah well there would be different stps
right uh so
um
yeah so that integrality Gap is uh I
believe like something around 0.83
six something like that okay so there is
no internet to get proven for the max
three card classical Max 3 card in the
sense of like you know uh the one that
we have from Max cut
okay uh the best that we could hope for
to get for the classical problem is 0.94
up to MP completeness but uh uh this is
the best that you have I guess
okay
um
this is this is the attempt to have an
approximity on this one exactly
yes which probably uh yeah I wouldn't be
able to uh you know I have to uh but let
me just cut the corners of this one and
then uh okay so here's what happens
um uh this was this was for Max 3 card
but you can imagine Max K cards for that
you would need
Sigma i k to be
identity
or you can imagine also uh this class of
problems called linear unit games so in
general you can apply this method to uh
this framework to
device approximation algorithm so for
example for max four cut
the approximation ratio that you know
following all of this the approximation
ratio that you would get would be uh
point
84.
uh
so
in general you can imagine
this class of currency satisfaction
problems so what are they let me just
quickly
they would they are kind of satisfaction
problem with
a bunch of variables that would take
values in some finite field
okay and they would have uh
they would have some linear equations
and linear inequation as uh they're
constraints so they would be like things
of this forum
or an equation
not equal to C like for example like
it's a Max K Cuts we have the in
equations okay and
so these are in some finite field and um
and this class would contain like um a
bunch of problems like all the Max K
cards
all uh so-called linear unique games
and so on
um all right so now uh
you know uh so I I gave you the example
of Max 3 cup but you can do the same uh
kind of a story for for other constant
satisfaction problems
and
right I want to talk about the
representation right so how would you
show that how would you like uh prove
that there is a representation for this
algebra that is non-trivial okay so let
me maybe finish by by uh saying a few
points about that all right um
all right
and then we can have a half an hour off
break please yes in the vector program
or x i and product X J is be greater
than negative one-half yes is this some
of you also have a constraint to enforce
in the non-commuting program
um
so in in fact uh you you could do that
you could you could imagine that uh uh
the entries uh that the inner product of
these xxjs are going to be at least
minus half yeah
no it is not implied so that you know
one way to see it is the following if
you uh
um
so this STP that I wrote down is the
first level of STP relaxation of uh this
uh non-community volume optimization
okay if you go to the second level of
this STP you are going to get
um
you're going to have a larger moment
Matrix and you want that to be positive
semi-definite and uh
there is a minor of this larger moment
Matrix that also has to be positive
semi-diffin if you focus on that it's a
three by three Matrix you're going to
get that the inner product of
x i x j in any optimal solution must be
uh at least minus half
if you write down the second level of
the relaxation okay uh so that's one way
to see it but there is a geometric way
of saying it as well for the classical
case
for us yes it implies around the PST you
you know here we wrote down the first
level STP but we borrow one little
constraint from the second level STP
which enforces the any solution to be
like that the first level STP
uh uh doesn't see this
right uh the first level doesn't say
this but because uh it follows from the
second level STP you can always take it
back and enforce it on the first level
okay
but in the case in the classical case
you don't even in the vector case you
don't even need a this STP business to
get this uh just by virtue of the fact
that you want to be able to at the end
of the day round to a third root of
unity you can always assume that these
vectors uh would have in a product that
is at least minus
uh so uh as for constructing
representations for this algebra it's
usually easier to think about
representation theory of groups right so
um
let's let's think about the group that
is generated by
by these
generators and relationships well we
have a bunch of things that are not you
know in the language of group like what
is this adjoint and what is this uh
minus you know but still let's try to
kind of like put some of these relations
so we want them to be
order k
and we want them to be uh we want them
to have this exotic anti-commutation
right so I can write it as this
and then minus Sigma J inverse Sigma I
that's it right but then this minus one
is a little bit of problem we don't have
that in a group right so
but this is something that they can
easily deal with we can just add as an
extra generator J and let that to
represent minus one and since we want it
to be -1 we can add the relation that J
squared is one
okay and that well -1 commutes with
everything so you want Sigma J to commit
with everything
sure that this group
presentation of the group has a
non-trivial representation and what do I
mean by that if it has a representation
that sends J to minus I
then I have proved that this this is
going to be the group algebra of this
group so I have constructed a
representation for this algebra okay
um
so how would I do that well the two key
things in the proof of uh the existence
of representations of this G
uh
and they are the following
if one focuses on
this subgroup generated by
Sigma I inverse Sigma J Sigma J inverse
Sigma I
you already see that they have this
anti-committing relationship with one
another but it's not going to be true
that everything that is generated here
is going to be anti-committing with one
another right some of them are going to
commute some of them are going to
anti-commit but they're going to commute
or anti-commute and this is the property
of poly operators the only group
that does this is the party group you
know the only uh
um like if you write down this uh
algebraic relations that you want to
satisfy you get a group and the only
representations of this group
are the quantum matrices that we are
familiar with the only non-trivial right
so g0 from from this observation you can
show that g0 is isomorphic
to the polygroup yes the g0 is like
generated by all those things from all
hygiene pairs is that right or are you
fixing it actually repair oh
yeah for all IG good questions
Sigma K because that is that obviously
oh it doesn't it either commutes or it
anti-commits
yes because because you can write down
Sigma H Sigma J as Sigma I inverse Sigma
k
Sigma K inverse Sigma I
right so you can
imagine J exactly
so if you have something else like Sigma
L inverse Sigma
R so you know
by ritual of the fact that you know each
one of them like uh either commute or
anti-commute then you get
uh so I'm not you know this is not going
to be a full proof of the thing but
um just uh
enough to for us to believe that this is
probably group this big subgroup of this
G in fact G divided by G zero is going
to be ZK
or like the cyclic group of order K so
it's it's really a big subgroup of the G
and
another thing to notice is that Sigma I
by conjugation if Sigma I acting by
conjugation and these guys
is is going to leave the subgroup in
variance it's not too difficult to see
that like if I uh conjugate uh Sigma J
inverse Sigma k
by any Sigma I I am going to get
something that is still going to be in
g0 so in other words Sigma i's are
normalizer
of g0 and we're familiar with
normalizers after power they are the
Clifford group
so all you need to do at that point is
to show the existence of an order K
element in the in the Clifford group and
you can do that
okay so to construct a representation
for this
okay all right so that's um
we're right on time actually
[Applause]
yes
I'd like to recap what you said about
the when you drop three and you can
still go with one two three prime he
said oh yes
so the rounding there would essentially
be you know dropping the
like in that QD oh yes sure uh so there
are two two things
exactly so if you have if you have an
operator X
any operator x uh and uh
you write down it's it's a singular
value decomposition which is going to
give you two matrices u and v which is
going to be the singular vectors and the
singular values right
then uh x minus U star V
in for business Norm
is going to be less than x minus y
where y
is a unitary
unitary operator so suppose you X is any
operator you want to know what is the
closest unitary operator to its
right
well the answer is that you drop the uh
D and um
uh and and that operator is going to be
a smart the short the closest thing yeah
sure but
um
again as you probably mentioned it
started here
close this unit change for Venus Norm is
also the best in terms of the customer
exactly because do you see a Romania
storm here
exactly
yeah it is kind of yes okay so what were
you saying about what the approximation
ratio oh the approximation ratio for
this uh I think it's the required
which is not as close as uh you know
yeah but uh there is a way to fix it and
in fact uh this the randomized rounding
that I was saying that we think we hope
that that we can prove that it's going
to achieve a 13 over 15 approximation
ratio is
a way of salvaging kind of like uh the
linear algebraic rounding method but you
just sprinkle Randomness on top of it
just uh very much like a government
surrounding up uh
yes
okay
how do you so
how do you think about
these things and where you are and in
terms of like are you
so from the outside it looks like a
little bit like okay well there's this
representation that happened to be very
important there was a choice here to you
know use three or use three to five but
some of these things seem a little bit
um
non-principle maybe we sort of try them
and see what yeah from the way you
presented it so I'm wondering now that
you've sort of had a
like is there an analogy that you can
make as to where you I don't it's a very
open-ended question sort of like how do
you see this and are you seeing this as
somehow it's the underlying structure of
these groups that are being sort of
pulled out and dealt with or is it like
the groups are a tool and that
eventually 10 years from now there's a
much different way to see what like it's
very principles right oh well
um yes
um as you know for
you know if if we could have one to four
that would have been the most principled
approach to it right there would be no
uh question right but and you know just
choosing one over the other that's the
kind of part that is not principled
right uh and it could be that uh why not
even a totally different algebra right
so that's the thing I'm suggesting that
it could be that you you have to make a
choice you have to choose an algebra
here I give
two different algebras that could work
right one of them uh generalized Val
Brower the other one I called it
generous Clifford
and I demonstrate to you that these are
the approximate ratio that you can get
right but make no guarantee that there
could be some other algebras that could
achieve something better
in an approximation to these relations
yes you could you could do that yeah you
could uh
you could try to come up with an
approximation approximate representation
of these things but then these are so uh
inconsistent with one another that when
you even set any to be equal to two
uh there's no hope to kind of satisfy it
but yes approximately maybe you could
maybe you could have something like that
and then uh
in fact okay so maybe I presented two
extreme points of it like you can
imagine that you could maybe Lambda
weighted this and one minus Lambda this
so a convex combination of these
relationships and uh you know uh
uh and uh so uh does that make sense
like you could have like that this times
Lambda plus this times
one minus Lambda should be zero okay
um and then uh hope to you know there
you can find a representation there you
don't have any problem right uh so for
uh for any value of Lambda you probably
would be able to except for these
extreme points where the zero one
right
but good idea
um
foreign